[Musique]
des suppléments alimentaires qui
contiennent des substances dopantes
illégales et dangereuses simple 3 400 $
par semaine pour garder tamas aller
chercher de la coque tour du coeur ce
sont des stéroïdes anabolisants qui sont
vraiment interdite sur le marché au
canada
[Musique]
difficile à croire mais des suppléments
alimentaires contaminés par des
substances dopantes telles des stéroïdes
sont en vente libre dans des magasins au
québec
le plus troublant dans cette histoire
c'est que les autorités semblent prendre
à la légère cette menace à la santé
publique
nous avons fait enquête est ce que nous
avons trouvé est préoccupant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet homme s'entraîne quotidiennement
c'est un mastodonte dans début de la
trentaine il admet prendre des stéroïdes
depuis dix ans moi pas voir mon corps
pour raser 290 livres moins de 10 % de
gras ça me coûte très cher c'est un peu
de fraîcheur on va parler de 3 400 $ par
semaine
bon quand on fait quelque part annie a
imputé à une vingtaine de millions de
dollars
n'est pas seul à consommer des drogues
uniquement pour grossir ses muscles
c'est très très répandu présentement de
plus en plus à chaque année des jeunes
comment s'en prennent de plus en plus
tôt et ceux ci est automatiquement
l'utilisation des storage ou d'en
croiser magique pour augmenter sa masse
musculaire
paul s approvisionnent principalement
sur le marché noir
mais il lui est arrivé d'acheter dans un
magasin de suppléments alimentaires
un produit qui est interdit le mt pour
ce roman j'ai pris du mt 1 giga s'est à
plusieurs reprises
sauf que c'est des produits que moi même
je la meuse a attaqué parce qu'ils sont
trop forts que c'est surtout sans
vraiment le haut niveau du tu sois les
gens pensent que si des choses
naturelles et parce que c'est
naturellement le feu vert ils peuvent
abuser s'y posera tout au contraire les
traits nassif donc les jeunes abusent
aussi produit par décevoir effets sur
leur santé
est il possible qu'un produit comme le
d'autres qui seraient interdits soit en
vente libre sans client sache à quel
point ils peuvent être dangereux
[Musique]
je vois aussi les analyses amadou sy de
studios et des trucs comme ça chaque
jour dans la feuille du port la forêt je
vais aller voir super trouvé ça et ma
volonté stockholm et osterholm et au bol
tribaux leur extrême
avec effet de réel mais cela
erdan c'était l'été dernier au
centre-ville de joliette dans la région
de lanaudière
en observant même 66 cellulaire aux
prestations apprécié ici se trouve un
magasin de produits naturels très
populaire vis ta santé appartenant à une
ancien culturiste
marc c'est le nom fictif de notre taupe
dit muni d'une caméra cachée
il ira voir s'il peut trouver des
suppléments alimentaires contenant des
substances interdites comme de
l'éphédrine la testostérone ou des
stéroïdes
j'ai une amie qui m'a donné un restant
de bouteilles s'était produit qui
m'intéressait c'était du mrt ouais ouais
je vais maintenant c'est pourri d'être
fiers en fait c'est sûr je l'essayé
patriotes sa mère
j'ai pas nuits lyriques ça j'aimerais ça
va racheter d'un fonds
la commune n'hésite pas un instant et le
conduit vers le comptoir vitré où les
produits sont à la vue de tous la même
chose parce que c'est marqué métaboles
là dessus c'est comme un peu je me tue
c'est un choix ce soit au travail
émeutes et soit souvent travaillé
oxymétal route royer métaboles hockey
parce que c'est pour grossir après son
valet travaillé en qualité le must super
chasse avant parti n'y a pas que le mtg
est à 75 marques demande des styles 1
qui sont-ils les coûts c'est ce que je
voulais essayer pour moi rien c'est une
fille mince et beau-fils baquet mais je
m'attends à perdre pour ma blonde
d'ascoli alex honnold s'empresse de
protéines en poudre à côté par jour
theresa tard sans bagages puis tu fais
poser sur le carburateur mais deux
gardes parce que je passe à côté on
souffre un sol
à la sortie du magasin marks montre ses
achats il en a pour 4 100 dollars
pokémon
ça va être le prix nobel à créteil
chercheurs sans vraiment on parle du
metas theron
méthot bol et le décuple ex un deuxième
arrêt nous nous rendons à rosemère au
nord de montréal
la boutique nutrition experts situé dans
un centre d'entraînement ça lui va bien
merci
c'est pour la boutique de supplément
j'ai posté ici tu sois mais testeront
métropole et des caps l'accent ça aussi
c'est des produits qui m'intéressent
vers ce ne soit un français sur six
jamais sur l'autel du brunch agacé aussi
ici les produits ne sont pas sur les
tablettes mais sous le comptoir c'est
plus prudent
m
michael soit plus grave
le vendeur propose à marcq produits rose
du nom de stanols qui ressemble
étrangement à stanozolol le stéroïde
utilisé par ben johnson aux jeux de
séoul
il ya 20 ans
cet été
primo les noms 1500 eurent changé comme
leader en fait les profs m'ont un peu
plus comme légal
m
ok c'est ce que j'ai pu sortir
primobolan métaboles justement
le proverbe et durable'
à rosemère la récolte a été fructueuse
cinq produits suspects 325 $
[Applaudissements]
je te sens troisième visite de notre
taupe dans un magasin de suppléments
alimentaires
cette fois à montréal il est toujours à
la recherche de produits contenant des
substances dopantes hockey ou au magasin
optima sport markt demande une facture
la réponse du propriétaire le laisse pas
tout faire une facture chose de plus
pourquoi pourquoi les partis légaux tout
aussi illégal mais que sont donc ces
produits interdits que l'on retrouve un
vente libre qui stimule rendre plus
forts ou font maigrir
qu'at-il dans ces flacons
nous les avons confiés pour fins
d'analysé au laboratoire de liens rs
santé à montréal accrédité par le comité
international olympique
alors dans les produits je vous dirai ce
que j'ai trouvé les plus choquants c'est
bon premièrement ces produits là aussi
sont des composés qui contiennent de
l'éphédrine et de la caféine et sol et
deux en combinaison c'est interdit au
canada c'est également interdit aux
états unis il n'y a pas que les phares
green la plupart des autres produits
sont aussi illégaux le reste ce sont les
stéroïdes anabolisants qui sont vraiment
interdite sur le marché au canada dans
le rapport que madame ayotte a produit
on remarque la présence dans les flacons
d'une multitude de stéroïdes ainsi que
diverses formes de testostérone donc ça
c'était un des meilleurs vendeurs et
c'est vraiment les trucs qui sont
dangereux dangereux immédiatement
mais ce qui rend les produits encore
plus dangereux et le fait que leur
étiquetage est inadéquat ou carrément
faux ce qui est écrit là sur le côté ça
veut absolument rien dire
y'a pas moyen de ski à l'étiquetage puis
en plus de toi même si l'étiquetage
était était chimiques les avait un sens
chimique ce qu'à l'intérieur ces
passionnantes
puis souvent la personne qu'il vînt va
avoir ce dos discours scientifique donc
on a l'impression qu'elle connaissait
je tairai sujet on travaille avec
tribaux l'ain où on travaille avec tous
je t'explique la différence cibola 4
plein de testostérone grosse pour garder
la nasa allait chercher de la copie
d'autres aussi car nous avons fait
visionner à michel portman docteur en
physiologie et ancien entraîneur de
bruny surin les séquences filmées en
caméra cachée il n'en revenait tout
simplement pas je me suis sûr quelques
mois du si je regarde ça merde c'est un
grand premier au déjeuner compris mais
où tout l'économie ont proposé notre top
des recettes sur leur utilisation sans
vraiment connaître les dangers
ce qui a fait bondir michel portman ces
dangereuses et c'est affolant
quand même quand on propose comme ça
c'est vraiment risqué et des risques de
cancers et des problèmes testiculaire
des problèmes ou blanc de sexuel des
problèmes cardiaques également des
myopathies qui peuvent survenir il ya
plein de problèmes secondaires qui sont
issus de ces anabolisants là
si on n'en meurt pas parce que là encore
les gens qui n'y sont pas capables de
supporter ces d'au-delà les effets
secondaires donc son devrait faire peur
à tout le monde me d'ébène important
c'est aussi ma faim toujours en mangeant
hockey ses traits à sexy la capsule
ouvrir des restaurants agences à
trouverait énormément donc attention
c'est des produits qui passent par le
fouet pour se préparer a ajouté li haï
l'alcool pour arriver puis
pourquoi trouve à angers face vous non
plus
les blocs sont sues stock picking manche
poutine kentucky attention le tgb
pensez pas que les sportifs d'élite vont
prendre des produits comme ça dont la
pureté est inconnue c'est vraiment
dessus et madame tout le monde qui sont
qui sont très vulnérables par
s'approchèrent ou parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont capables d'en avoir
relativement facilement alors soit c'est
un problème de santé qui est important
de ce problème de santé publique
revenons à la visite de l'été dernier de
notre taupe j'évite à santé à joliette
là comme il lui parle de son
propriétaire pour se donner davantage de
crédibilité avec je suis québec
au canada anglais
nous avons joint au téléphone le fameux
alex en fait il s'agit d'alexandre
paiera le propriétaire du magasin il a
refusé de nous donner une entrevue à la
caméra mais n'a pas nié vendre des
produits ils l'écoutent tout le monde
c'est bon c'est bon on veut toujours
écouté la venue au magazine hello
la comique qui elle a tout nié en bloc
était moins bavarde que son patron
bonjour bonjour mon nom c'est vrai je
suis allé jusqu'à donner sessad et
rigolant metouali par green est ce que
vous connaissez ça cadrait pas vendu
farine connaissez ça des piolenc non
plus vous en départir la mnt
lolo13 avec sa vente ce genre de
produits leurs services capeder on dit
que 10-2 redit que les greens d'éclat
fait cependant jones à rosemère de
propriétaires de nutrition experts a
prétendu ne pas savoir ce qui se
trouvait dans les produits vendus par
son employé du crédit cds grec a remonté
de près
[Musique]
à montréal ce petit mas sport le
propriétaire richard atallah a tout
avoué
lorsque nous l'avons joint au téléphone
lui aussi n'a pas voulu nous accorder
d'entrevue à la caméra c'est pas vrai
oui oui j'en ai vendu ce qui était mon
temps passé sous sol était petit j'ai
recommandé aux pme oui ce que j'aurais
voulu c'est que dans notre pays où on a
un consensus que ce sont des médecins
qui doivent prendre soin de notre santé
que santé canada aucc nos autorités
vérifie que ça ne se presse pas de
vendre ces produits là ça c'est interdit
c'est pas pour rien que c'est interdit
santé canada le mr la liste des
interdictions ces disparus des états
unis aussi donc comment se fait-il qu'on
puisse vendre ça avec tous les contrôles
qu'on est sensé revoit un inspecteur de
santé canada a mené une opération
magasin de joliette
il y a un an il n'a saisi qu'un seul
produit de feurs greenext crime
le mélange explosif d'éphédrine de
caféine étonnamment aucune suite légale
n'a été donnée au dossier même s'il
s'agit d'un produit interdit
l'individu a pu lier à bien
voulu nous donner sa façon volontaire
son inventaire il ya aussi signé
l'entente comme quoi ils cesseraient la
vente de ce produit et de toutes autres
produits similaires
alors on avait conclu que le risque à la
santé avait été bien contrôler mais si
tu veux d'avoir décrit dette on fire
bridge où j'étais chargé 75 pièces avant
le fait qu'ils se soient fait taper sur
les doigts n'a rien changé aux
comportements d'alexandre paiera puisque
nous avons retrouvé dans son magasin
plusieurs produits illégaux trois mois
après la timide de réprimandes de santé
canada qui vont rien parce qu'ils
veulent mais c'est sur le bull
ce n'est pas à nous de trouver les
derniers mois c'est pour en arriver là
les bleus 2 rouges massacre
est-ce que vous avez cherché à savoir
qui produisait ce produit entre autres
de faire tout ça venait c'était fait ce
que vous avez cherché à savoir où vous
êtes arrêté uniquement en magasin ou
dans ce cas ici le propriétaire le
monsieur en particulier nous a confirmé
que c'était un produit que lui importait
lui même directement des états unis
débout s'avoue satisfait
ça nous a satisfaits ou un cru qui nous
donnaient des réponses vrai et
[Musique]
as tu un flacon que nous avons acheté on
indique qu'ils ont été fabriqués au
new-jersey nous y sommes rendus
nous n'avons trouvé que l'entrepôt
aucune trace de pro matrix sur d'autres
flacons on trouve une inscription est
dit qu'un qui proviennent du brésil
après vérification nous avons constaté
que le lieu de fabrication n'existe pas
se pourrait-il que les suppléments
interdit que nous avons achetés étaient
fabriqués à montréal
impossible de le dire fort greene
exprime mt stanols primaube aulas tous
les produits que nous avons acheté porte
la marque pour matrix
elle appartient un montréalais qu'à ses
bureaux à dollard des ormeaux
constantine a star is sarr s est aussi
le propriétaire de la compagnie mvp qui
fabrique des suppléments alimentaires
naturels
nous lui avons affaire à de nombreuses
reprises de s'expliquer devant la caméra
mais en vain au téléphone il a dit être
victime d'une conspiration visant à
nuire à ses intérêts couvreur
constantine a star is prétend ne plus
commercialiser la marque pro matrix
depuis 2002
au magasin de joliette l'a commis à ce
ponte à nîmes en fait le lien entre sa
compagnie mvp et pro matrix fourniront
promat respect svp c'est la même chose
dans le fond qui l'amènent représente un
tout autre si condom
le lien entre mvp pro matrix s'est
renforcée lorsqu'un propres employés de
konstantinos harris a proposé un client
des produits pro matrix lors d'une
négociation d'affaires descente
prometric sas be continued
étrangement le site internet faisant la
promotion et la vente des produits de
pro matrix a disparu après nos appels
chez constantine a star is on constate
aussi que leur distribution a été
récemment discontinuer et que les
vendeurs non plus en stock
oui discount et nude krimo la stac
constantine as a risk a pris
connaissance de nos analyses sur le
contenu des flacons que nous avons
achetée a finalement rompu ses liens
avec nous j'ai déjà fait un message dans
sa boîte vocale
il accuse de perturber le marché
il a laissé son après répondeur un
message qui laisse songeur
[Musique]
pourquoi des gens serait-il menacé après
notre enquête
simi par qui de quoi semble vouloir nous
mettre en garde constantine à sa guise
dans un récent rapport la grc mentionne
qu'il ya eu ces dernières années un
accroissement de l'implication du crime
organisé dans le trafic des stéroïdes et
qu'ils proviennent principalement de la
chine et d'europe et dans une moindre
mesure des états unis
prends ton assez au sérieux la vente
libre de suppléments alimentaires fait à
partir de substances interdites
il semble que non puisque santé canada
refuse de jouer à la police et que la
police refuse d'intervenir dans les
magasins nous ont fait à santé canada
qu'est-ce qu'on
le rôle de faire le mandat de faire et
on choisit toujours l'outil le plus
efficace en même temps comme vous l'avez
mentionné où on a quand même à peu près
150 inspecteurs pour le pays entier
alors comme vous pouvez apprécier on
peut pas rentrer à chaque magasin
pendant ce temps des consommateurs vont
continuer à les acheter
sans trop savoir ce qu'il ya dans les
flacons et ceux qui les fabriquent et
les distribuer continuons à les vendre
sans être inquiétés suis lassé des
mythes qui doivent nous les prêts
seraient des endocrinologues qu'on doit
avoir des raisons médicales importantes
pour les tendres alors que l'or on ne
fait plus à faire du tout avec un
professionnel de la santé
visiblement ils n'ont pas les
qualifications pour faire ce qu'ils font
parce que s'ils ont les qualifications 6
vendre des trucs comme ça sur le marché
c'est des crapules mais si l'on pas les
qualifications ben c'est aussi dangereux
mais s'ils savent et le contenu de ces
produits loeb qui les vendent pareil en
pleine connaissance de cause et des
chrétiens
[Musique]